behind the scenes of the iconic opening  group sequence was quite the production  a significant amount of people had to be  totally in sync  emma watson commands the screen with her  performance even while surrounded by  multiple cameras following her every  step  when watson was talking to inanimate  objects in the movie  she was also doing the same behind the  scenes  madame de la grande bouche is no cgi  both candelabra lumiere and human  lumiere managed to impress with  energetic leaping  as for the winter wonderland outdoors  well it's a bit more of a blue screen  studio kind of a situation  even behind the scenes watson radiates  grace descending the staircase